[Music]
if the council hadn't come to us and say
said we've got this bungalow we want to
build and we want to build it for Jake's
needs we would never have moved we lived
in Elms well in a two-bedroom and
terrace with a big step into the front
door it was completely inappropriate for
us and moving here has been the missed
best move we could have ever had Jake
can't walk says I find it incredibly
painful to walk stairs because of
mitochondrial disease no we don't have
to do any stairs to talk moving a step
into the front door it's all completely
level here and that for us is absolutely
perfect the difference just to our
day-to-day lives is absolutely
incredible you know in the summer Jake
comes home from school and he says mummy
I'll go and garden now and he could take
himself off into the garden for me
hearing that from my little boy is
incredible during the build but you know
we were in touch all the time getting
progress update before the build
Stiles's we're having regular meetings
about what was happening and I was in
regular phone calls and emails with the
illnesses that we have the move was
absolutely vital so for other families
in the situation that we were in if
other families could be as lucky as
we've been then that would just be
perfect thank you very very much for
building the bungalow thank you for
letting us live here and live such a
happy life in this bungalow
we are so happy and we love living here
thank you
thank you very much water house
you
[Music]